mass curfews mass quarantines lockdowns
everywhere but let's talk about the mass
surveillance want to fight Kovac 19
there's an app for that
facial-recognition gps bluetooth they
make it easy cameras and drones keep an
eye on us too
this is a kind of watershed event
surveillance is really spreading
everywhere it's all about tracking
people to contain the spread but some
want to know who's policing the police
so how will our governments protect our
health and our privacy and how do we
make sure all this extra surveillance
doesn't stick around longer than we
needed
[Music]
this coronavirus has been tough to
contain because it spreads so easily
his white governments are trying to do
two things monitor people's health and
keep tabs on where they are and
surveillance technology makes that a lot
easier Singapore's government released
this app that logs everyone you bump
into the German government has an
optional Smart Watch app that tracks
your pulse temperature and sleep and if
you're quarantined in Hong Kong you have
to wear an electronic wristband police
are also flying drones this US company
says it can even tell if you're sick
anonymize data on social distancing
heart rate respiratory rate and fever
detection that's a lot of technology to
help stop the spread of kovat 19 privacy
advocates have noticed I'm not against
surveillance itself we need to make use
of whatever technology is available to
fight the epidemic and to ease the
economic crisis but it should be done
carefully technology has to be used of
data gathered in a way that's necessary
and proportionate to a particular end
thing is even before the pandemic we
were giving away a lot of our data
already we share personal information
online all the time even the stuff we
don't post like what we Google and what
we buy we give our fingerprints to
governments when we travel or to our
smartphone to unlock the screen
companies like Apple and Samsung have a
record of our faces intelligence
services use facial recognition - and
all of that data is being collected
sometimes with sometimes without our
consent
police in the UK have been building up a
facial recognition database by scanning
people in designated areas
last year they used the tech to track
down more than 450 suspects and Wales
don't know how long it's being stood on
that database and for what purpose
Russian police also use facial
recognition to monitor protesters with
biometric data collection seemingly
available at nearly every street corner
your authority say they can easily catch
criminals other countries like India and
Kenya are facing in a national ID card
that's linked to your biometric data
possibly the world's most privacy
invasive digital ID system not such very
sensitive data about people so imputing
their iris scans they're in and shape
their GPS without the card people can't
access things like loans or health care
and now we have a pandemic governments
everywhere expanding their power to
bring this global threat under control
in China they've harnessed one of the
most pervasive surveillance systems in
the world cameras are pretty much
everywhere one for roughly every eight
people police once use facial
recognition to track down a wanted man
at a concert with 60,000 people cameras
are even used to enforce China's social
credit system which ranks businesses and
citizens in their behavior back in the
40s and 50s that was all done through
humans asking their neighbors lots of
questions now that's really all gone hi
tacky and because of Kovan 19 it's gone
into overdrive
in Hebei where the virus first broke out
police use cameras drones and facial
recognition to quarantine 56 million
people even as lockdowns ease up
millions of Chinese people are still
being monitored in some cities they have
to love their health and travel history
in an app that generates a color code to
leave home or go shopping security has
to give you the green light if your red
or yellow you're really not met to be
moving around it's not just China
surveillance is being stepped up
everywhere so how far is too far you've
all her re a historian and author says
it could open us up to abuse it is of
course focused on the disease itself the
system needs data about what's happening
inside your body your body temperature
maybe your blood pressure maybe your
heart rate but once
surveillance goes under the skin it can
start be used for many many other
purposes they can know not only that
you're watching but also what you are
feeling what makes you angry what makes
you laugh it gives some clue about your
political views or personality and the
implications of that are extreme it can
go all the way to the establishment of
new totalitarian regimes worse than
anything we've seen before that's
obviously a worst-case scenario what's
to stop that from happening well that
the key question right that's why I must
international as well as other NGOs and
digital rights organizations are very
closely tracking the rollout of these
systems - yabba could say we should
scrutinize the emergency laws
governments are crossing right now often
with little or no public debate the UK
hungry Russia the Philippines Thailand
they've all done it Israel tried to the
government has turned to the secret
police and authorized to use some of the
skills and technologies it initially
develop
to monitor and control the Palestinians
with the Israeli Supreme Court put on
the brakes we know especially in Israel
that measures taken in an emergency have
this nasty tendency long outlast the
emergency we need to be extremely
careful about what we're allowing and
for how long
will we be able to turn that back once
this is over and then there's the
language some politicians have been
using I feel it is a in a sense of
wartime president you must act like any
wartime government no Sons on game there
are plenty of examples where conflict
has led to governments expanding their
powers 9/11 is a good example our enemy
is a radical network of terrorists and
every government that supports them our
war on terror begins with al Qaeda the
Patriot Act was brought in just 45 days
later in the name of fighting terrorism
and it was criticized for expanding US
government surveillance some of those
powers are still around human rights are
born out of the modern world's turmoil
now is precisely a time where we need to
protect them and uphold them so how do
we make sure the authorities don't abuse
the data they have on us in the name of
fighting the pandemic this is not a war
this is a healthcare crisis if you want
to put somebody in charge
put a nurse in charge not a soldier or a
general some actually think governments
in Asia are doing it right in Singapore
and South Korea for instance officials
say the data they're collecting now will
be deleted later there's also been in
some cases a lot of public data and
public transparency around why they're
doing things and how they're doing
things such that people understand you
know it's not just necessarily a
paragraph citizens should
demand that first of all their privacy
be protected as far as possible and that
any increase in monitoring of the
citizens be accompanied by an increase
in the monitoring of the government so
maybe that's it
sure surveillance technology will help
contain the pandemic but while they're
watching us we might want to be watching
them we don't know when we'll be back on
the start here set but not to worry
we're still going to be bringing you
more episodes any way we can in the
meantime our website aljazeera.com has
all the latest on the corona virus
pandemic I'll see you next week
you